The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: All right, so this
is where we got to last time.
So we were on the road to
deriving the leading order SCET
Lagrangian.
We said that there
were some things
that we had to deal with,
in particular expanding it.
And we started out,
as a first step,
getting rid of two of the
components of the field
that we said are not going
to be ones that we project
onto in the high energy limit.
And that led us to this
Lagrangian right here,
but we haven't yet expanded it.
We haven't yet separated
the ultra soft and collinear
momenta or the ultra soft
and collinear gauge fields.
And so in order to
do that, I argued
that you have to make
multipole expansion.
And I talked a
little bit about what
the multipole expansion would
look like in position space.
And then I said, it's better for
us to do it in momentum space.
And we started to do that.
And we're going to
continue to do that today.
So first of all, let's
just go to momentum space.
So I've called the field here--
since it's not the final field
that we want, I introduced a
crummy notation for it, Cn hat.
And once we get to the final
field, it won't have a hat.
And that'll be the one that
we keep using from then on.
So let's take this hatted guy,
which is not the final guy,
Fourier transform him and
talk about doing things
in momentum space.
In momentum space, I'm
going to make an analogy
with what we did in HQET.
In HQET, we split the
momentum into two pieces.
We had a piece that was large
and a piece that was small.
And then we could expand.
I'm going to do the
same thing here,
split it into a large
piece and a small piece
where I'll call the
large pieces the one
in the lambda components.
And then the small
piece will just
be all the pieces that are
of order lambda squared.
So if you draw a picture for
this, it looks as follows.
How should I think about
what I'm doing here?
Here's how I want you
to think about it.
So let's draw a two-dimensional
picture in minus perp space.
In plus space, there's no split
because there's no plus here.
So it's really in the
minus and the perp space
that we have to make a split.
Yeah, let's see.
All right, so I'm
going to draw a grid.
And the way I want to
make this split precise
is I'm going to think--
OK, so I should have maybe made
my axes in a different color
to distinguish
them from the grid.
Let's make them orange.
So the way I want to think
about these two types of momenta
is I'm going to think about
these Pl's as discrete
and the Pr's as continuous.
So let's think about
the Pl's as labeling
these points at
the center of each
of these boxes in the grid.
This one was supposed to be--
that's fine.
My squares are
not the same size,
but they roughly should be.
And so then we can think
about, if we specify
some momentum in the space--
let's say we specify momentum
that points to this point right
here.
The way that I can
point to that point
is I take one vector that
points to the center.
And then I take
another small vector
that points to that point.
The large vector is the Pl.
The small vector is the Pr.
OK, so this guy here is Pl.
Maybe I should make the other
one a different color, Pr.
And so the way that we
should think about this
is in the following sense.
We should think about
the average spacing
in between these
grid points here
is something that gets
a power counting that
makes it of order Q lambda.
And the average spacing between
grid points in this direction
is something that
makes it order 1.
But if I ask about
distances inside a box,
if I ask about a
distance like this one,
that's of order lambda squared.
So to get between
boxes, you need
to make a big jump to
the larger momentum.
But to move around in a box,
that's only small momenta.
AUDIENCE: So why can't
you have order lambda
basically inside the box
in the P minus dimension?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So you could.
So you can ask, where is in
order lambda momentum in the P
minus?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
IAIN STEWART: And
it's in a nether land.
Either way, you
can think about it
as being part of
this one or that one.
It doesn't matter.
Because technically, if I
just talked about minus,
I'd only be interested
in separating a 1
and a lambda squared.
And whether I call this
lambda squared or I call it
lambda or I call it eta--
let eta equal lambda squared--
I'm only trying to
separate two things.
So if you talk about some
momentum that's in between,
you could ask the same
question actually about,
what about a lambda to the 3/2
momentum in the perp space?
And that's the same question
you just asked about the minus
space, right?
And that's something
that we don't really
care about because there's
not going to be momenta
that are scaling like that.
So we don't really care
about separating it.
OK, so Pl are
discrete grid points.
And Pr-- continuous.
And this picture also makes
clear that, if you take any P,
it uniquely is given
by some Pl and some Pr.
If I point at any
place in this grid,
you can tell me exactly
which Pl I should pick
and then what Pr I should pick.
This is, in some ways,
just going to be a tool.
And in the end of the
day, we can kind of
dispense with this picture.
But it'll be a useful way of
thinking about what's going on
and getting to sort of the
final results that allow us
to dispense with this picture.
So what about integration?
So if I integrate over
all P and P is collinear,
what does that mean?
So it corresponds to summing
over all the grid points
and then integrating
over all the residuals
except for one location.
And that's the special box
here that has label equal 0
because we know that the power
counting of the collinear
momentum is such that it
always has to have a non-0 Pl.
And so the one box where
Pl is equal to 0, 0,
that particular box doesn't
have a collinear momentum.
And actually, that
box is exactly what
you think of as the
ultra soft momentum.
So if you have an integral
d4P and P is ultra soft,
there's no sum.
And you just have interval d4Pr.
And that's like integrating over
the 0, 0 location in the grid.
OK, so you can see
that together we
cover all possible places
for an integration.
And we actually don't
do any double counting
with this setup.
What am I going to
do with my fields?
Well, because of this split
into two different pieces,
I'm going to say that my fields
actually can be labeled by Pl
and carry Pr also as an
index or as a function of Pr.
So in order to
make this explicit,
we're going to write
our Fourier transform
guy with a label Pl and
an argument Pr like that.
So the name label comes from
the fact that we do this.
And there will be some
analogies with why
we called this a label in HQET.
We'll see to what extent
that analogy carries through
in a minute.
Another thing you should
note from this grid picture
is that you have separate
momentum conservation
in the label and the residual.
So if you think about some
integral d4x of something
that you split between label
pieces and residual pieces,
then the right way of
thinking about this
is that you have a discrete
[INAUDIBLE] delta for the label
and then a continuous
Dirac delta
for the continuous variables.
And there's some 2 pis.
And so this is what
would be meant by--
if you have two
momenta that are equal,
you know that they're
in the same grid square.
And then they have the same
little green arrow as well.
That's what that's saying.
So when we talked
about what happens
with the multipole
expansion in position space,
we said that
effectively you have
a non-conservation of momenta.
OK.
We had a field at 0.
We worked through
what that meant.
And it meant, basically,
that the momenta
was conserved on the other
line, but not on the one
that you were doing
the expansion on.
The nice thing about
this type of setup
is that we have
conservation of momenta,
but we actually have two
conservations of momenta.
So we don't give up
momentum conservation.
It's just that we go
over to a picture where
we have two of them.
So let me show you
how that works.
Let's say we have an
ultra soft particle,
and it's hitting
a collinear quark.
The collinear quark,
because it's collinear,
carries two types of momentum.
It carries a label
P and a residual.
But the ultra soft guy,
it's only residual.
So let's just call
that k residual.
There's no label to
that ultra soft guy.
So if I just look then what
this guy's momentum is,
it's P label for the large
piece because that is not
affected by the ultra soft guy.
And then it's P residual
plus k residual.
OK, so we have a conservation
in the residual space,
which is the standard one.
And we have a conservation
in the label space,
but the ultra soft particles
just don't contribute to that.
So we have two
conservation laws.
And we just know that certain
fields can carry these label
momentum and other fields can't.
All right, well,
since Pr here and kr,
the residual components, is just
standard quantum field theory--
the only thing that's
special is the Pl.
For the Pr, what we're going to
do for the residual momenta is
we're going to transform
back to position space.
And that's kind of what we
do in HQET as well, right?
We treat this guy in momentum
space as a label and this guy
as a position space
for the residual.
And the reason we really want to
do that is related to locality.
And I'll say some
more words about that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
IAIN STEWART: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So this top equation--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are you bounding
the d4Pr by lambda squared,
or is there some reason why
the integral should fall off
before you get
there or something?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, we're
going to talk about that.
So, so far, this
is just notation.
If you think about it
from this grid picture,
you'd think some
hard walls put in.
That's not quite the right
way of thinking about it.
It's actually not right
for several reasons.
And we will come back
and talk much more
about what the right way
of thinking about it is.
But the physical picture
that you're in this box
is the right way of
thinking about it.
The tricky thing is that
these boxes are infinite.
Each of these boxes is infinite.
And we'll have to
see why that is.
In what I've told
you so far, you'd
think that the d4Pr would really
be a box with some fixed edges.
And it's going to turn
out that the d4Pr--
we're going to use dimensional
regularization-- it's
going to be an infinite box.
But we're still going
to be able to do
exactly what I'm telling you.
And it's going to make sense.
We're going to
want infinite boxes
to avoid breaking symmetries,
like gauge symmetry and Lorentz
symmetry.
And we'll come back
and see how that works.
So in some sense, what I've
told you is a Wilsonian story.
And we're going to have
to make it into a more
continuum friendly story.
But the moral of
the story, the way
you think about where
these momentum modes live,
what kind of momentum they
carry, that is just true.
So that part of the
story, which you
can think of so far
as Wilsonian, is true.
And it's OK to think like that.
So we'll see actually what we do
in practice a little later on.
Where this will
really come in is
when we start wanting to
think about doing loops,
but we won't get there
for a little while yet.
So the conservation
law in the residual
just corresponds to locality.
We learned all about
locality yesterday
in [INAUDIBLE] seminar.
And so we can make things
local by just going back
to the x base for
the residual momenta.
OK, so we go back
to the x base, which
is the Fourier transform
conjugate variable
to the residual momenta.
So the fields we're
actually going to use
are these ones, where we
Fourier transform back
in the residual,
these guys here.
So it's kind of
like HQET, where you
think about this part
as momentum space
and that part in position space.
OK, so if you talk about
ultra soft interactions--
you can see it from over there--
they conserve the labels.
So there's label
conservation of a field
for ultra soft interactions.
The label of the
field here is the same
as the label of the field there,
so that ultra soft guys do not
change labels.
So this is Pl.
This is Pl.
And if this is ultra soft,
it's still labeled by Pl.
And the thing that can change
is the residual momenta.
And that's now
encoded in locality
in saying these fields all
sit at the same point x.
On the other hand, the
collinear gluons cause us
to hop between boxes.
So the collinear gluons
are label changing.
And that's what's
different than HQET.
In HQET, we don't
really have interactions
in the theory in the Lagrangian
that do that, but here we do.
So if we have a
collinear gluon come in,
the collinear gluon,
again, carries both labels
and residuals if I
just draw the labels.
And this is some Ql coming in.
And this will be Pl plus Ql.
And so the label of the
outgoing field has changed.
There's one more label.
And that's this n, right?
We also label these
guys by a direction.
And that is unchanged also by
the collinear interactions.
So it's preserved by both
ultra soft and collinear
interactions.
It can only be changed
by hard interactions
where you would have
some hard production that
could produce, say, two guys
in two different directions.
And those type of
interactions are typically
only going to occur once in
your quantum field theory,
kind of like a decay, a weak
decay where it occurs once.
And then you do perturbation
theory around that.
Hard interactions
are that way, too.
So as far as dynamics
is concerned,
this label n is
something that you
can think of as being
conserved for the field.
It's not going to be
changed by the Lagrangian,
for example, all right?
OK, so, now, we have
kind of what we want.
And now, I want to
write the action
that we had before
in terms of this guy
and see what it looks like.
This split of these guys
into a Pl and Pr or Pl and x
allows us to expand
very easily in momenta.
It's allowing us to do the
multipole expansion because we
have two things to talk about.
And we just can compare them.
So let's put the
pieces together.
So Cn hat of x is the
full Fourier transform
of this Cn twiddle.
And that can be split
for a collinear guy.
We can split the measure,
and we can split the phase.
And we can write the
field in this way.
And then we decided that we
wanted to use this field.
Let me see, [INAUDIBLE]
two pis here.
So that means we take this
measure, we take this phase,
we take this guy, and we write
it back in terms of that field.
So that leaves, if we
want to relate the field
that their Lagrangian was in
terms of in terms of this field
that I told you we're going to
use, it's this equation, OK?
All right-- a little
bit more formalism.
So we're going to actually want
to have two different types
of derivatives, derivatives
that can talk to the momentum
conjugate to x and
derivatives that give this Pl.
So we define two types
of derivative operators.
One is just, if you like,
a standard derivative
in the x base of this guy,
acts only on that coordinate.
And that derivative scales
like lambda squared.
So that's residual, picking out
talking to residual momenta.
Then we need something that
can give us the labels.
So we define an
operator that does
that, which we'll call curly p.
It doesn't care about x.
And it's just defined
to give the Pl
mu of the field it acts on.
So there's no plus
component to this.
There's an order
1 minus component.
And then perp is order lambda.
I want to say how
big that guy is.
So then we have a power counting
that tells us how big the p is
and how big the partial is.
And we can compare them, and
we can expand in them, OK?
So the bottom line
is that we now
can just say that, like we had a
comparison for the gauge field,
we have a comparison
for derivatives.
And so this is exactly
analogous to what
we said before where we
had M bar dot A ultra soft
is much less than N bar dot
A collinear and A perp ultra
soft being much less
than A perp collinear.
And in fact, the way
we're setting things up
is going to make the
gauge symmetry also easy.
Because by gauge symmetry, these
derivatives and these fields
should go together.
They are the same size
in the power counting.
And these guys should
go with those guys.
So we're kind of doing this same
thing we thought of for fields
we're doing for momenta here.
So when we talk
about gauge symmetry,
this will make gauge
symmetry easier,
this homogeneity between the
derivatives and the fields.
So that's one of the powers
of thinking like this.
OK, so let's see that
this notation is actually
kind of friendly.
So let me try to
convince you of that.
It looks kind of daunting, but
maybe it's not so daunting.
So let's look at this guy,
which was equal to this.
So what I can do is I can
take this and replace it
by e to the minus i label
operator dot x, right?
But the label operator then
doesn't care about the sum.
So I can push it through.
So as an operator, it
goes through the sum.
I have that.
And for a lot of purposes, in
a sense of suppressing indices,
we can just use a
simplified notation
for this guy where
we suppress the sum.
So we were thinking about
this as a discrete sum.
And we can always write out
that sum if we get confused.
But we could also
adopt a notation
where we suppress the sum.
And for many
manipulations, just like
you might suppress some
indices in a quantum field
theory, that's perfectly fine.
And having this label operator
makes it easy to do that.
So if you have, for
example, field products,
say I had two fermions, we
try to make the notation work
for us as nice as possible.
Well, if you have
a sum of momenta
and then it's exponentiated,
if you have a product
and it's a product
of exponentials,
then it just becomes the
sum in the exponential.
So this is true if we do
it for two fields, right?
I'd have the label
operator acting
on this guy and that guy.
And if I were to write out
this twice with two sums,
then because the product
of those two exponentials
can be just written as a single
exponential, this is true.
So this guy acts on both fields.
So in this sense, the
notation is friendly.
And what this phase factor
here is really doing for you,
if you think about it,
if you think about it
in a whole product
of fields, it's
just when you Fourier transform
giving the label conservation,
OK?
So there's going to be this
kind of overall e to the minus
i p dot x.
And it's just sitting
there to conserve momentum
in the label space.
So that's its purpose.
OK, so there's one
more step that we
have to do before we start
talking about the Lagrangian.
And that's this
little caveat that I
had right at the
beginning where I said,
let's consider only quarks.
So far, we've only considered
the quark part, not
the antiquark part.
So let's see what we want
to do about antiquarks.
Technically, the way that the
field theory wants to work
is that the quarks
and the antiquarks
kind of want to be
different fields,
but that's very cumbersome.
And so we're not
going to do that.
And we're going to find, again,
sneaky notation to treat them
as one field even though
they want to be two.
The reason that
they want to be two
is because, if you look at the
phase factor for the quarks
in the antiquarks in the kind
of standard mode decomposition,
it has the opposite sign.
So look at the mode
expansion in QCD.
I can write it in a covariant
type notation or with a d4p p
if I put in the
proper projection.
And then we have the quark
part with the e to the minus ip
dot x.
And then we have antiquark
part, our b daggers,
and the e to the
plus ip dot x, OK?
So let me think of that as
a psi plus plus a psi minus.
And we've so far only
talked about psi plus.
So for psi plus of x,
we have a sum over Pl
not equal to 0 e to
the minus i Pl dot
x of sort of a Cn Pl plus of x.
So this is the case we did.
If we were to repeat everything
we did for this case, then what
we would get for psi minus--
and this is why I say that
they want to kind of look
like separate fields--
is we'd get a plus i Pl dot x.
And in this notation, if
you think about the P0,
the P0 is the sum of the
P minus and the P plus.
So saying that, in this
mode decomposition,
P0 is greater than 0
for these two equations
and when we go over to sort
of a collinear scaling,
it becomes that Pl
minus is greater than 0
in these equations.
OK, so that's the sense in
which these are different.
With a positive Pl minus, we
have an opposite phase factor
for these two guys.
And in both of these
cases, it's true
that just as kind of a way of
remark, we still have this.
That didn't change, remember.
OK, but talking about minus
and plus fields would just
make our life really
difficult. Actually,
when we first derived SCET,
sometimes you're bone-headed.
And we went through everything
in a much more detailed way
that I'm going to
present it to you now,
wrote out everything in terms
of plus fields and minus
fields because of
this little issue.
Then we noticed
the following thing
that I'm going to tell you, that
we could just put everything
back together with
a simple definition.
And that's because really the
only difference is this sign.
So if we want a kind
of convenient notation,
we can do the following.
So far, if you like, we
have this guy with Pl's
not equal to 0, but the Pl
minus should be greater than 0.
So we can make use of
kind of negative labels
by the following trick.
Just define a
composite field that
looks like this where I put
the minuses and the pluses
back together.
If I have a positive
Pl minus here,
then that's giving the pluses.
If I have a negative
Pl minus here,
then that's giving
the minuses because
of what I just told you.
We don't just think about this
guy as having plus Pl minus.
We allow it to have negative.
And we take the
negative Pl minuses
as a way of encoding what's
going on with this guy.
So we have different
possibilities for M bar dot Pl.
And if you like, what
the plus guy is doing
is destroying particles.
And so let's say
this is for the--
if I think about Cn of--
let me make my chart like this.
If I think about what
Cn of Pl is doing,
it's destroying particles and
the antiparticles are created.
But the antiparticles
are going to be
created for the
opposite sign of the Pl.
And then if I think about
what the barred field would
be doing with this
notation, if the M
bar dot Pl is greater than 0,
then the particles are created.
So this guy is
really just the field
we were talking about before
if Pl is greater than 0.
And if Pl is less
than 0, it just
repeats the whole story
for the antiparticles.
OK, so I could
write everything out
in terms of this
plus and minus field.
But if I just make
this simple definition,
I could put everything
back together
and just work in terms of
one field, which kind of does
what we're used to.
And it's just a sign convention
to remember for this Pl.
And that sign convention
is also easy to remember
because the Pl is really
following the fermion flow.
If you think about
the fermion, then
if you think about the physical
momentum of that fermion,
then the physical momentum
follows the fermion
in the case of the fermion.
And it's opposite to the fermion
in the case of the antifermion.
So here's a fermion
coming into some vertex.
There's a antiparticle
coming into the vertex.
And the Pl goes this way.
It follows the fermion flow,
whereas the physical momentum
is going this way.
And that's the sign we're
just keeping track of.
And so the P labels are
always following the arrows
of the fermion lines.
They're always along the fermion
number with the conventions
we've set up.
OK, so with that little
piece of notation,
we take into account the
antiparticles as well.
There's no real
additional complications
since any way you
draw a picture it's
completely clear
what's an antiparticle
and what's a particle.
And it just follows
your intuition.
And furthermore, because the
only difference in the mode
decomposition was that
sign and we've now
accounted for it by just
making the labels negative,
we have this equation,
too, for both particles
and antiparticles.
So we get the
opposite phase here
because this guy has
the opposite sign.
So there's really no
additional complications
from adding the antiparticles
once we set up this notation.
OK, any questions so far?
What about collinear gluons?
So the gluon field is
Hermitian, the original one.
And what does that
translate into?
Well, it translates into
the B's and the A's, right?
They're both appearing in the
decomposition of the field.
There's no B's.
There are just A's.
And if you work out, using
the type of body decomposition
that we're doing and
using the type of notation
that we're doing,
what that means,
it means that the star of
this guy just flips the sign.
So that's what Hermiticity
of the original field
becomes for this notation.
And again, because of
the theta functions
that show up in the
mode decomposition,
you can think of associating
ql minus greater than 0
as sort of destruction and
then ql minus less than 0
as creation.
If you want, although it's
not absolutely necessary,
you could adopt this convention.
And then that would just be
putting a particular direction
to your gluons.
And everything that we
said before goes through.
And in particular, if
we think of decomposing
sort of the hatted version
of the fields, then this--
just like before.
And we can just also,
again as before,
if we like, adopt the notation
where we suppress the labels
if we don't need them.
So the gluons really,
in some sense,
it's just simpler
because we don't
have to worry about the
particles and the antiparticles
because of their Hermiticity.
It's sort of they're
all the same thing.
And for most purposes, there's
no sense in even keeping
track of this convention.
So that's why I went
through it quickly
because the convention
is always kind
of obvious from the context.
If you're really talking about
production of a real gluon
or annihilation of a
real gluon, then you
can keep track of
the signs that way.
The fermions are a
little different.
So because any starred field is
just the negative of this guy,
we could always write everything
in terms of fields that
have no daggers for the gluons.
But for the fermions,
some of the fields
are barred or daggered.
OK, so what would be the form
of having a general label
operator act on some
combination of daggered fields
and some combination
of undaggered fields
where the gluons are
always undaggered?
Well, it just gives the
sum of these momenta.
And the way it does it-- so
sum of the label of momenta.
So I'm thinking of all these
denominators as label momenta.
I'll maybe not put the l.
And the way that
the convention works
is that we get a minus
sign for the daggered guys.
That's our sign convention.
And the reason for that sign
convention is effectively that,
if you think about
e to the minus i
curly p dot x on sum
5 p1 and then you
take the dagger of that, then
it becomes 5 p1 dagger of e
top the plus i kind
of p dagger dot x.
And basically, I'm
saying that I want to be
able to write that like this.
And that convention is useful.
So if I want to act forward
on this field, which
is a daggered field,
then I'm going
to take the opposite side.
And if I have a daggered p, then
it would take the plus sign.
And that convention
is the useful one
for keeping track of
momentum conservation
because then every field
has the same convention.
We just have e to the minus i
p dot x for every single field.
All right, so if we started
with some partial derivative--
I mean some regular derivative.
And it was acting on one
of our hatted fields.
So if I write it out in
terms of the labels--
put a Pl on it if you like--
we'd have that.
And so there's two contributions
from this derivative.
It either hits the phase
or it hits the field.
And so we can write it like--
if we go over to
the label operator,
we can write it that
this partial derivative
is the sum of two
derivatives, which then we
can take the sum over Pl
inside and write it as--
so every derivative for the
purposes of this exercise
is to convince you of the
sanity of the notation.
Every regular derivative acting
on one of these hatted fields
where we hadn't yet
decomposed momenta
just becomes a sum of
these two derivatives.
And that's just like the fact
that we split the full momentum
into the sum of the label
in the residual piece.
OK, this is the field version
of P mu equals Pl mu plus P
residual mu.
OK, but the advantage
of this notation
is that we can then drop the
partials if they're smaller.
That's the whole
reason for this setup.
So now, we can
expand because we've
split up both the
fields and the momentum.
So we're able to expand.
So let's go back to the
thing we wanted to expand.
So we had this guy.
And we wanted to expand it.
And now, we know
how to expand it.
We've set up a nice way of
doing the multipole expansion
by introducing some
additional notation.
So because of what I just
said and because of what I
said last night for
the gauge field,
we have a very
simple decomposition
for the covariant derivative.
It's the sum of a
collinear kind of piece
and an ultra soft kind of piece.
So this P mu plus i
partial mu is just this.
And the split of the gauge
field into these two pieces
is what we talked
about last time.
And that split of
the gauge field
actually led to some things
that we didn't talk about
that we'll talk about later.
So if we now look at
the components that
are appearing in here,
we can figure out
what to keep in each case.
And it's pretty simple.
Well, for the plus,
there's nothing to drop.
We just keep everything.
And there's also only
one type of derivative,
so we just keep this.
This is exact.
All terms here are
order lambda squared.
For the perp, we just
keep the collinear parts.
So if I write out
the other part,
just for completeness
we can drop those terms
relative to these terms.
Because these terms
here are lambda,
and these terms here are
order lambda squared.
So we drop these guys from
the leading order and then,
similarly, for the minus.
So here, this guy is
order lambda squared.
And this guy is order lambda 0.
So we drop this guy.
OK.
So now, just plug those
things into our Lagrangian.
And then we get the
leading order Lagrangian.
All of these phase factors can
be encoded in an overall phase
factor.
We get the full n
dot D derivative.
But for the collinear
parts, we only
get these piece, this piece,
and the piece over there.
And so you can think of that
as a collinear covariant
derivative.
No.
So sort of in the
obvious notation,
we take the two pieces that
are collinear and put them
into a collinear D and likewise
in the n bar direction.
OK, so this Lagrangian here is
the leading order Lagrangian
with this additional notation.
And if you like, we
have this kind of D
that has both pieces in it
for that n dot direction.
And then for the other two, we
just have the collinear pieces.
And that's the
leading order action.
Where we've carried out
the multipole expansion,
after we introduced notation,
it became something trivial.
So the power of the notation is
that, once you've swallowed it,
everything else is simple.
If I want to go to
higher order, I just
work out what these terms are.
Then I should also
worry about these terms.
And we'll do that later on.
OK, so what can we
note about this?
Well, one thing that
we worked out earlier
was that this should
be of order lambda.
And that actually implies
that, our new field,
we were just pulling out phases.
And that doesn't change
the overall power counting.
So our new field is of
order lambda as well.
And likewise, before
we sort of had a power
counting for the
measure, which you
can think of in our
new notation as a power
counting for this
thing, and that just
scales like lambda to
the minus 4 as before.
So all the power
counting that we
were doing even before
we sort of figured out
what the right field to use,
that all carries through.
And that's why I did it earlier.
OK, so what's going on
here, which I didn't really
spell out, but I
can spell out now,
is since this phase is
order 1, the power counting
from momenta induces a
power counting on the x.
And it's kind of the larger
momentum that dominates.
So x minus scales like
1 over p plus x plus--
remember in the
dot product, it's
always plus times
minus, a confusing thing
about light cone coordinates.
And so if you count up
the powers of lambda,
you get minus 4 of
them because you
get 2 here, none here,
and then 2 there.
So that's all going
through as before.
And then if you ask, what's
the order of the Lagrangian,
the Lagrangian density here
is order lambda to the 4.
Because we have two
fields, and then
we have a lambda squared
here and then a lambda here,
a lambda 0 here,
and a lambda there.
And our power counting
made that explicit.
So the whole thing
is lambda to the 4.
This lambda to the 4
of the Lagrange density
cancels the lambda to the
minus 4 of the measure.
And you get that,
when you integrate,
this is lambda to the 0.
And that's what we wanted.
That was our convention for
the leading order term, OK?
So the power counting,
nothing really changes.
We had a power
counting for momenta.
We just now have a power
counting for all these objects
that we're talking about.
What about locality?
Well, all the fields in
this Lagrangian are at x.
So it is local in
residual momenta.
We said that already when we
were drawing Feynman diagrams.
And that's just
true of the action.
And so what that
means is the action
is local at the smallest
momentum scale in our problem.
And we would have been
surprised if we'd encountered
anything different than that.
The action is actually also
local at the scale lambda.
Even though we adopted
this label convention just
to separate the momenta, there's
no inverse perp derivatives
in this action.
And so the perp derivatives
appear in the numerator.
And so it's actually
local at that scale, too.
And so if you like
this, we've just
written something that's
in momentum space.
And it's the momentum
space version
of locality at the scale lambda.
And we've hidden all
the momentum space
so it even looks local.
But if we were to write
out the indices again,
we would see that it's
the momentum space
version of locality.
And so the only scale
that it's non-local at
is actually scale that
we want to integrate out,
the hard scale.
And that's due to sort of the
presence of this kind of 1
over M bar dot Pl type factor.
So that we already
sort of saw earlier
when we were talking about
building up the Wilson line,
right?
We said, well, there's
some off-shell fields.
Let's start
integrating them out.
And we got inverse powers
of this M bar dot Pl,
but that was at the hard scale.
So we had no choice but
to integrate them out.
And you can think
about this factor here.
If it bothers you, you can
think about it in the same way
that it's not any worse
than what we already did.
OK, let's see if this
Lagrangian does what we want.
Let's look at propagators.
If we have a collinear
propagator with a collinear
gluon, say, coming in,
let's look at this diagram.
These are fields
in the n direction.
This is some guy that's Pl Pr.
And let me just take it to
be Pr plus for convenience.
Then if you look
at this guy and you
ask what that propagator
is, it comes out exactly how
we want it to come out.
So there's nothing
that gets dropped
in the denominator in
particular in the sense
that all components of the
momentum are showing up.
We're still dropping residuals.
But if we're just talking
about collinear particles,
then the residuals
are kind of redundant.
The purpose of the
residual's momenta
is when we're talking
about both collinear
and ultra soft particles.
So the other case
that we need to treat
is when we have an
ultra soft particle.
We could, of course, have
both of them at the same time,
but let's treat this case.
So we have Pl, Pl plus some
k, which is purely residual.
And now, this guy, because
of the derivatives,
these derivatives
don't see the k.
None of these
derivatives see the k.
So in the n bar in the
perp, we don't see the k.
It would look like that.
If you like, if you want to
make it kind of look more
like the Lagrangian,
convince yourself
that this is the inverse,
just divide by this factor.
Divide by this factor,
then it puts it under here.
And that's exactly what
this is doing if you
ignore the Dirac structure.
It's not playing a role
really for the propagator.
And same here, if you take
this factor, divide it out,
then you got the plus piece
which is this derivative.
And then you get perp
squared over minus.
And that's what happens if
you put this down stairs, OK?
For linear, all the
components show up
because we didn't drop anything.
For ultra soft, only
the plus shows up
because it only changes the
plus momentum of the collinear
field.
So the Lagrangian is smart.
It knows how to
deal with the fact
that the propagator should
be different for these two
situations.
And that was one of the
things that we wanted,
and we achieved it.
So even though the
Lagrangian doesn't
know what's going
to happen, it's
smart enough to deal with
any possible thing that
could happen and give
the right propagator.
So we don't have to
expand any further.
The Lagrangian knows how to give
the leading order propagator
for any situation that
we might be interested
in at leading order, which
are these two situations.
What about Feynman
rules for interactions?
So that's also interesting.
So if we have an
ultra soft gluon,
and let's say it
has an index mu,
there's only one
term that comes in
because it's only the n dot D
that had an ultra soft field.
All the other ultra
soft fields got dropped.
So there's only n dot A
ultra soft in the Lcc0.
And so there's only one term.
Things are a little more
complicated for the collinear.
And this is kind of
the price that we
pay for setting up the notation
that we did the way we did.
So this guy here has all terms.
Just by pulling a gluon field
out of any one of the terms
it can couple to any
component of the gluon field
just like in QCD,
but our Feynman rule
is a little more complicated
because of the way
we set things up.
And in some ways,
what's happened
is that we've made
the propagator simpler
for the collinear fields at
the expense of complicating
the interaction.
OK, so we couple
to all components--
the perp component,
the n component,
and the n bar component if
this is a collinear field.
So these are all
collinear fields.
So one way of thinking about
why that kind of had to happen
is the following.
What if we didn't
have ultra softs?
Imagine that we were going
through this whole story,
but we just had collinears.
Then you wouldn't
really need to go
through this multipole expansion
because there would never be
two momentum of different size.
And you could actually, just
for the collinears, use QCD.
The purpose of having
this multipole expansion
is really because we want to
talk about both of these things
at the same time.
In fact, if you
only had collinears,
you just boost to the
frame where they're not
having this boosted scaling.
It's really relative scalings
that the effective theory
is trying to encode, relative
scaling between collinear
and ultra soft or between,
say, two collinears going off
back to back.
That's where the power of
the effective theory is,
in relative thing.
So it's only when you have
two things at the same time
and you want to
describe both of them
that you get into the
kind of complications
we're talking about.
If you just have one thing,
then things are simple.
You could just use QCD.
But if you just had QCD
for the collinear sector,
you'd know that you have a very
simple Feynman rule, igTA gamma
mu, and a more
complicated propagator
because you'd have a P slash.
Well, here we don't
have any P slash.
The propagator, if you
write out the spin,
is simply n slash over 2.
But the P slash has to
come back somewhere.
And it's coming
back because it gets
encoded in the way we set
things up in this vertex.
So these factors of P slash here
are just reproducing P slashes.
Then in the full QCD context,
it would be in the propagator.
You can actually
work out, if you
start writing down Feynman
diagrams, that that's
exactly what's going on, OK?
So that's kind of
the price that we
paid for sort of making
a Lagrangian that
dealt with both things
at the same time
and made this part
really simple.
That part became slightly
more complicated.
But once we know
what I just told you,
we can oftentimes, you know,
carry out calculations here
by making correspondences
with the full QCD Lagrangian.
Sometimes that's done anyway.
They couple to all four
components of the field.
Actually, once
you start learning
how to deal with
numerators like this,
it's different than
what you're used to,
but it's just, in some
sense, as complicated
using this Lagrangian.
It's just that you're
writing things out
in components, which you
might not want to do, right?
Why decompose things
into components,
which we're doing here?
Why do that if you don't
have sort of something that's
projecting onto a component?
That's, in some sense,
the only complication.
OK.
And there's one other
thing, of course,
which is that the Lagrangian
also had terms like this.
So it's not simply just
one gluon interaction.
We could have, for example,
two covariant derivatives,
two of these perp covariant
derivatives, for example.
And there's a Feynman
rule for that, too,
which comes out of the
action that we wrote down.
OK, questions?
AUDIENCE: So I
guess this, I mean,
the effective theory is
reproducing the collinear
[INAUDIBLE] divergences of QCD?
IAIN STEWART: It is, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in [INAUDIBLE]
QCD, the higher divergence
cancel with interference
[INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: And
that'll happen here, too.
AUDIENCE: And you have to loops?
Or it's happening like a
leading order [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: No, you have
to look at loops, too.
So, yeah, there can
be cancellations
between real and virtual graphs.
And there actually can
be such cancellations
separately for ultra soft
gluons and for collinear gluons.
So we'll talk about what
you're talking about a little
later on.
But there is an important
point that I'll emphasize
since you ask the question.
If you ask about
the divergences,
the infrared divergences
of an ultra soft gluon, so
the ultra soft gluon, if we go
back to sort of where it was
living, it was littered here.
Collinear gluon was living here.
And if you ask
about divergences,
what the divergences
are coming from
are momenta going to 0 or
momentum going collinear.
And this guy here that
lives kind of here
can go both collinear,
and it can go soft.
So the names collinear
and soft, which
correspond to the names
collinear and soft divergences,
are not a one-to-one
correspondence.
An ultra soft
particle can actually
have both collinear
and soft divergences.
The collinear particle
can also actually
have both types of divergences.
And so the names are
associated to where
they live in momentum space,
not the type of divergences
that they're encoding.
If I wanted to do something
along the lines of setting up
the field theory to just exactly
correspond to the divergences,
well, first of
all, no one's ever
figured out how to do that.
But you could imagine
how it would be
different than what I'm doing.
Because if I wanted to
do that, then somehow
my collinear field would sort of
be sort of sensitive to angles.
It should be like
an angular variable
because the divergences are
coming from angles going to 0.
And it's not an
angular variable.
It's just a regular field.
So setting things
up in this way is
kind of how we usually think
of an effective field theory.
We're just talking about
momenta small or big.
And that's what we're doing,
but it comes in the sense
that you don't have a
direct correspondence
with the divergences.
AUDIENCE: So you have more
divergences [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: The
way of saying it
is that you have more
divergences in a way,
but they're the
same divergences--
yeah.
Yeah.
So you don't have
more divergences,
but really what's happening is--
so if you look at
this kind of picture,
if you look at the kind
of infrared divergences
that you could have,
so let's regulate them
with an off-shellness.
You could have
infrared divergences
that would be like that.
But when you do some
diagrams, there's
kind of infrared divergences
that could look like this, OK?
I'm just telling you something
that you have to trust me.
And this is coming from
an ultra soft scale.
P squared over P minus,
that's this hyperbola.
That's the scale
of this hyperbola.
And the P squared here is
the scale of this hyperbola.
What the effective theory does
is, any ultra soft diagram,
that'll give all these logs.
Any collinear diagram
will give all these logs.
You could say, well, P
minus is a hard scale.
So really the only the IR
divergences are just P squared,
but the effective theory
is kind of dividing it up
into these two types of logs.
And that's actually going
to be useful for us.
We'll see that that
allows us to do
some things that are
not so obvious how
to do in the full theory.
So, yes, it is kind of splitting
and IR divergence in these two
different types of terms,
but that's actually going
to be something that's useful.
Because in some sense,
there's two physical scales
in the infrared.
There's a sort of
collinear hyperbola
and the ultra soft hyperbola.
And the effective theory
is making that explicit.
Other questions?
All questions have
been good so far.
Keep asking them.
AUDIENCE: Could you try
using two different lambdas
for the ultra soft
and the collinear?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So you could if there
was a physical reason why
you wanted to.
And the thing is that, if
the lambdas order each other,
then there's no point.
If there's a hierarchy,
then what that would change
would be that the n dot D
should get expanded, too.
But if the n dot
D gets expanded,
then kind of what is
happening is you're really
decoupling everything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
And so you're kind of losing
the dynamical connection that we
have so far in this theory.
So I think it's
not so interesting,
but it's worth thinking about.
OK.
We're going to erase this.
So now, that we have a
leading order Lagrangian,
it does everything
that we want it to do.
We can use it to calculate
Feynman diagrams.
It defines the leading
order collinear
sector in the effective theory.
There's one more
thing I want to do.
And that's come back to the
fact that I told you before,
but now that we can
actually make more explicit.
And that fact was, when we
were talking about currents
and integrating that
off-shell particles,
we saw that you start
with these guys.
You start attaching them.
And you end up
with a Wilson line.
I'd now like to make it obvious
that that kind of manipulation
always is true, that we can
always get rid of this field
and put it in terms
of a Wilson line.
And the notations
that we've introduced
are going to allow
us to do that.
So let's have a little
aside on that fact.
So if you are in momentum
space, the Wilson line
has an equation of motion, or a
defining equation if you like,
that's this.
This defines the direction,
that the Wilson line is
long n bar dot n bar direction.
And the x and the minus
infinity are telling you
what the end points are.
So this is the
defining equation.
You can look back
at Peskin if you
want to see how that all works.
And that's the defining
equation in position space.
But we've just advocated
for a kind of momentum space
notation.
So what's the corresponding
equation to momentum space?
It's pretty simple.
If we go over to our
momentum space Wilson line,
we just go over to our momentum
space covariant derivative.
And the defining
equation is this.
So the notation, in some
sense, is pretty simple.
We just have to switch objects.
If we write out what
that derivative is,
then it's that, OK?
So now, consider
the following thing.
Consider this
combination, but let
me think about it as
an operator equation.
So let me think about
it as if there could
be something to the right.
If there's something to
the right, than the P bar
can act on that thing, too.
So I get 0 if the P
bar acts on this thing.
But if the P bar
acts through, then I
get just P bar on the operator.
So as an operator
equation, I can
trace the O. This
is true for any O.
And we have this
operator equation.
But I know something else I
know that the Wilson line is
at e to the i something.
And actually, it's unitary.
So W dagger W is 1.
And again, in momentum
space notation,
that's kind of
the obvious thing.
W dagger W is 1.
And that means I can
multiply this equation here
on the left or the
right by W daggers.
And so if I do that, let
me multiply it by W dagger.
And I can write i n bar dot
Dn is Wn P bar Wn dagger.
So the gauge field, g n bar dot
An, because of gauge symmetry,
it's always going to show up
in the covariant derivative.
So it's always going to
show up in this combination.
And this equation
is telling me I
can switch that for Wilson lines
in this P bar if I want to.
I could have also multiplied
things the other way around
and written it P bar.
So sort of by way
of completeness,
I could have written
that as well.
It's also easy to convince
yourself of the following.
1 over P bar is Wn dagger
1 over i n bar dot D W.
And 1 over i n bar dot D--
I'll check that I got the
daggers in the right place.
But these two equations
are true, kind
of the inverse of
those equations.
So how do we check that?
Well, just multiply
this times this.
You should get 1, right?
And if I multiply,
say, on the right here,
then the W dagger here
kills the W dagger.
Then the P bar kills the P bar.
And then the W
kills the W dagger.
So those are true.
And so we can put this into
the Lagrangian if we want.
And we can do what I said,
that we can actually,
if we want to, get
rid of the n bar
dot A field for the collinears
in terms of Wilson lines.
And we'll use this from time
to time when it's convenient.
If we use the D Lagrangian, the
Lagrangian becomes this thing.
So that 1 over i n bar
dot D becomes this thing.
And in some sense,
you might think
that this is easier
to expand if you
know the expansion
of the Wilson line.
And we just have to
let a 1 over P bar act
on this full
combination of fields.
And it just gives
the total n bar
dot P momentum of that
full combination of fields.
I claimed this was true.
And now, I show you in a
kind of non-trivial case
how, with these
operator manipulations,
we could just quickly
go back and forth.
And it's related
to the fact that it
appears in this combination.
We'll talk more about
gauge symmetry later on.
I'm alluding to it
from time to time,
but we'll talk about it
more precisely later on.
We have to do this story for
the collinear gluon Lagrangian.
And much of this
is just repeating
what we've said for the
quarks for the gluons.
And once we know how to write
down the covariant derivatives,
then it's actually
not so complicated.
And there's just one
little complication
that we should be
careful about, which
I want to emphasize to you.
And so we'll go through it.
Let me write the Lagrangian
in QCD in terms of traces.
And let me use a
general covariant gauge.
So this is a general
covariant gauge fixing term.
That should be called
the gauge parameter tau.
Then we have some
ghost fields as well.
And of course, g mu nu is
the usual g mu nu A TA.
And that's my sign convention
commutator of two derivatives
with the pi over g.
So we do the same
steps to get SCET.
And so really, if you
think about writing
all the g's in terms
of D's, we already
know how to split
the D's in terms
of ultra soft and
collinear parts.
And so that's what we do.
Let me write out a D, which
is kind of a leading order D.
And we'll just set
up some notation.
And then I can just basically
write down the answer.
So let's set up a curly D that
has all the sort of pieces that
will survive at leading order.
So all the pieces that survived
were the collinear pieces
and perp in n bar and then, in
the n direction, both pieces.
And effectively, I'm just
changing all the regular Roman
D's in my gluon action
into these curly D's.
And that's almost
the entire story.
So from a kind of power
counting perspective, once
you take into account
that, when you dot things,
n's are always dotting
with the n bars,
so it's this times this.
So this is lambda squared.
This is order lambda 0.
This guy dots into himself.
So you get lambda
squared there as well.
So for power counting purposes,
when you start squaring things,
they're all going to be
homogeneous with this setup.
So basically, that's
what I'm saying here.
And then there's
one complication,
and that's this
partial derivative.
Well, there's two
partial derivatives.
There's one there,
and there's one there.
So this is in the
gauge fixing term.
These terms are both
related to the gauge fixing.
And then those terms, actually,
I want to make them covariant.
So let me define one more thing.
I want to make them
covariant, but I
want to make them only covariant
under the ultra soft part
of the action.
So here is just
pulling out the pieces
that would have the
ultra soft field making
a derivative that I'll
call curly D ultra soft.
So one way of
thinking about that
is that it would be like
background field gauge.
In background field gauge,
you'd make this partial view
into the D mu of the background
involving the background field.
And that would be a
background field gauge.
So from the point of view
of the ultra soft field
being a background
field, it's very natural
to have a replacement
that looks like this.
And that's one way of arguing.
Really what's going on
in the effective theory
is that this is general
covariant gauge for A n.
That's what we want
it to be for A n mu.
This should be the gauge fixing
term for the collinear gluons.
And it shouldn't be
breaking any gauge
symmetry of ultra soft gluons.
So we'd actually
like the Lagrangian
to both have gauge symmetry
for collinear gluons
and a separate gauge symmetry
for the ultra soft gluons.
Since this guy is supposed to be
gauge fixing for the collinear
gluons, we don't want
it to be doing anything
to the ultra soft gluons.
And that's accomplished if
we make this replacement
that i partial goes to
i curly D, all right?
So we could write
out what Lcg0 is,
but it's just these
two replacements.
Since we're out of
time, I'll just say that
and, you know, sort of write
out the fields and the notation
that we developed, OK?
So we'll talk more next time.
What we'll do next time is
we'll talk about symmetries.
We'll finally talk
about gauge symmetry.
And we'll talk about
other symmetries.
And in particular,
symmetries are
going to be important
for understanding
how much of this story that I've
told you really carries through
once you start doing loops.
Symmetries protect you from
certain loop corrections.
Gauge symmetry, for
example, connects terms
to all orders in
perturbation theory.
And we'll see how those
things kind of work next time.
Really, the story I've told
you so far is all tree level.
We haven't done any loops.
One way of handling
what loops can do
is by looking at
symmetries and saying,
once we impose those
symmetries, what's
the most general possible
things that loops could do.
And we'll do that next time.